did you see that the libs of tick-tock
creator got doxxed by taylor lorenz oh
yeah so disgusting i loved libs of
tiktok i mean we wouldn't know about
these maniacs i think otherwise and i
wouldn't sit on tick tock watching what
a teacher from minnesota was saying
about you know their gender pronouns
otherwise there's not quite enough time
in the day and uh and so libs of tick
tock did a great service
um
and uh yeah taylor ends of the
washington post that's just such
disgusting baby long article do you read
it no i didn't read the whole art long
article serious yeah i wish they'd ever
looked at hunter biden's laptop story a
similar length
um
i mean corruption in the first family
um would strike me as being a much more
interesting subject than who runs libs
of tick tock
but then you know
washington pose has his own priorities
but taylor lorenz is someone who broke
down crying on msnbc not long ago
talking about online harassment
yeah all these people are
bullies who whenever they've finished
bullying people
pretend to be a victim
whenever they get caught out they cry
um
kathy newman phenomenon
bully somebody and then when you're
caught out behaving badly you present
yourself as a victim
nice
nice uh turnaround there very very
common so i think it was julie burchie
who coined the term cry bullies for
these people
uh cry bullies is a great term for our
era what do you mean by that cry bullies
are people who who go around bullying of
them and then um when they're caught or
in any way criticised cry
just immediately turn themselves into
the victim everyone knows this from
children i mean there's a certain type
of child who does that and they should
be slapped or you know in a country or
allowed to slap a child um
or you know otherwise
you know disciplined to not behave like
that
uh
you know
these are sort of grown up eric
cartman's and maybe not even growing up
there's sort of eric cartman like
they're horrible bullies and nasty
people who when it's not going for them
going wow wow what do you think is the
problem with libs of tick tock as a as a
channel is it because it's just bringing
attention to things that the left would
rather people not see it's not it's just
left him tricky it's just this is what
i mean i don't look at tick tock
um
and by the way i think it's a highly
unstable platform and obviously it's
chinese communist party direct
brainwashing slowly i did one video at
the time yeah all those things
and um
uh so so yeah obviously um you know
these teachers and others who
say these ridiculous outlandish things
there was one who even said she was a
witch did you see that one no there were
some teachers like you know i'm a witch
i told the students that they i had
questions and that was that was fine i'd
say
make it a bit harder for us i mean you
know
actually say
i also practice witchcraft or something
from me as being
no
it seems to me like it's a a warning
shot to any future potential
people that would consider doing the
same sort of thing because yeah you know
someone post something on tick tock
you're not not doing it to get attention
yeah like the the whole reason that
you're doing it is to get attention but
maybe not by six hundred thousand people
on a twitter account yeah yeah they
don't they want to be famous they don't
want to be infamous
um
and uh
once something highlights it to a group
they would never have got to otherwise
who don't see it favorably it becomes a
different thing of course
um
i mean it's a form of that that thing in
the area the context collapse phenomenon
that occurs with
social media all the time you know
context collapse being when the
an out group discovers an in groups
discussion and doesn't view it what's an
example of that oh
banter between friends on texts for
instance
where a group of guys banter about stuff
and including bad taste stuff
joking about girls or whatever
somebody leaks it and an out group
discovers it and thinks
how disgusting the way these men talk
about women durham university got popped
for this a couple of years ago uh for uh
there's i mean people are sort of wise
up to now but yeah um
right rugby teams quite often you know
get done over for it um
some an out group discovers an in-group
discussion and
you know it's understandable that
that um
that that happens in our era because
everybody has access to the click of a
few buttons to expose an in-group's
discussion
and it's really hard sometimes to
discover what the context would be of a
particular discussion
um so i mean that is something that goes
on all the time at the moment but
uh
but libs of tick tock is simply
exposing what an ingroup was hoping to
be able to say to to itself and it's
been discovered by an out group
but the out group really doesn't like it
because it's teachers you know and
things like that it's like
if if it's just we i mean there's that
one person on lives of tick tock i've
seen several times a totally deranged
individual a man who dresses as a woman
and says he's trans and uh and and i had
a lipstick and like a hairy chest and
and like he says you know
um
yeah he he can't understand why people
don't think he's a woman and call him
sir and things you know i guess it's a
you got a hairy chest and look like a
dude
um that's the problem i'd have thought
you know and uh but there's like this
this particular guy that he's like comes
back repeatedly like he's on one of them
he's like you will respect us
you will respect us and go i don't want
that person anywhere near
members of the public
uh it's really interesting to discover
those people but but
it's just but what the washington post
did was was was basically a punishment
beating
on the woman who who runs the lives of
tick tocks a punishment beating and a
warning to others well the editor said
that it was completely in line with the
journalistic standards at the washington
post well that's true but they amended
the article to remove her
real estate license that's right because
that had doxxer did you know that
there's another online influencer with
the same name as the person that founded
libs of tick tock who's the fallout from
this has been so hard that a person that
isn't the person that runs it but has
the same name has also been getting
harassed online
doesn't surprise me at all it doesn't
surprise me at all because say that
lorenz turned up at that lady's house
yeah yeah there's a video sorry there's
a photo of her standing at the door yeah
through the sort of she's just a really
nasty piece of work chloe it seems like
it's not the first thing that you know
this is the first time i've been
introduced to her um lots of people uh
in america
in media knew about her thought she was
a kind of rogue unpleasant bad operator
and um
this has just proven that i mean i mean
of course
it's vile behavior
and as i say i mean there's so much
that's important to to write about and
in america of all places
so many stories such a rich environment
for real investigative writing and
journalism
and uh to be going and exposing the
identities of citizens
who are reposting things from tick tock
would strike me as being a very strange
journalistic priority
um but don't forget
truth dies in darkness as the washington
post tagline says truth dies in darkness
so
their view of themselves as the
washington post is that absolutely
our democracy would not run
the world might not be free
unless they can dox take glimpse of tick
tock what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace